oh i can see something funny here okay
is he barefoot why would you do that who
would you suspect most likely to do this
well robert perez when he couldn't pass
the ball to me against man city he did
the same thing the only thing he didn't
fall
that would be robert
[Music]
hi i'm terre henry and this is write my
skills for sports bible
okay let's go so bowling here
the blue team is on the ball what
did he just do that wow
[Applause]
wow wow wow wow can i say that again
when the guy comes around you can see
that he's waiting for it because he
knows the goalkeeper is not in his goal
doesn't matter for me whether you are
mature or not amateur or whatever it is
if you use your brain
you're a good player in my book okay
outside
oh okay wow it's always spectacular when
you see a bicycle kick right
but the cross also i played with the
national team and general sister was
always looking to do bicycle kicks or
or volleys or or stuff like that i can
see something
funny here
right okay
now but first and foremost is he is he
barefoot
why would you do that i mean why
that's why of your former teammates
terry who who would you uh who would you
suspect most likely to do this
well robert perez when he couldn't pass
the ball to millions man city
he did the same thing the only thing he
didn't fall that would be robert
okay small kids okay
ball wow okay
okay it's going alone a little messy
okay oh it's always nice to see kids
playing that's how he should be that's
why he all started for all of us
you could see right from the start that
he was never going to pass that ball to
anybody
he was playing alone i like that
memories
okay now we see back to oh okay
wow that's a goal and a half ball comes
back to the net whoops
flick it that's a a matt leticia goal
that's
uh very good you can see that he means
that all the way
wow and then for the keeper it's
impossible to think that he's gonna
shoot from there
what a finish
oh okay wow that's on an easy skill you
know
it's it that new way you know when you
hit it
kind of here and the ball goes a bit
like uh the the free kick of ronaldo
against uh postmove was it
brilliant skill that's that's hours of
repetition by the way
that would have beat any goalkeeper in
the world because nothing you can do
because it goes up and down well done
okay oh what's gonna happen
wow okay well done yes
first and foremost you have the audacity
to do that that's great that's what you
want to see
it succeeded that's a goal that's
something efficient
well done all right free kick
yeah i mean listen if they had tried to
do that they would never succeed
but obviously they messed it up the best
is the guy with the hat
he's celebrating like they worked on
that he's acting like
like it was rehearsed look at him look
at the celebration
come on mate that's luck so in third
place
for me will be the bicycle kick crossing
the air a bit behind
the striker and you have the audacity to
go and get it really high keep it on
target
or the finish you know it's not an easy
thing to do at all
in second place the the flick put it on
the side
lift it with the side of your boot over
his head
i don't know if right from the start
that's what you wanted to do but it
surely reacted
well and what a finish and the winner
for me is
where it all started all of us being a
kid
you don't worry about anything he just
took that ball
and he was never going to pass it and
rightly so by the way because he scored
at one point he put his head up to see
what the goalkeeper is
and then what a nice finish and nice
celebration also
that's all football is all about little
children being happy
i'm terri henry and that was write my
skills for sport bible
that was nice you've got a score
oh he's missed it
that is terrible the the chip balling
behind is perfect
the runs good everything's good until
the last until the last moment
and he's got three options as well and
you just chose the wrong guy